عن موضوع صحي يستهل الكثير او يستهلكه
الكثير وادمن عليه
البعض بالطبع انتشر طبعا على نطاق واسع
كمنتج ترفيهي لا سيما بين الشباب في المدن
مما اثار القلق الحديث هنا عن سجائر
الالكترونيه المنتشره جدا
استراليا مشاهدينا تم الاعلان عن تدابير
صار
مه تدابير تلزم الشخص بتقديم شهاده طبيه
لاستخدام السجائر الالكترونيه وبيع
السجائر الالكترونيه في الصيدليات فقط
وزير الصحه
قال ان المنتجات اسهمت في خلق جيل جديد من
مدمن التدخين في استراليا وان السجائر
الالكترونيه باتت المشكله السلوكيه الاولى
في المدارس الثانويه ممتده وصولا الى
المدارس الابتدائيه طبعا ليس فقط في
استراليا في الولايات المتحده مشاهدينا
ظهر في السنوات الاخيره ما يعرف بالسجائر
الالكترونيه الصحيه
او سيجاره الفيتامينات الالكترونيه والتي
تدعي انها تعزز التركيز وايضا تقوي
الوظائف المناعيه لكن اداره الغذاء ودواء
الامريكيه شككت عادل طبعا في صحتها فكيف
تواجه دول العالم وباء التدخين وما تفرضه
من اجراءات الان س الى ذلك مع لميس
ابراهيم
[موسيقى]
سنويا في فرنسا
ينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور بسام
منصور الاختصاصي في امراض الجهاز التنفسي
وطب العنايه المركزه دكتور صباح الخير
صباح النور يعني السؤال اليوم انه هل
بالفعل ما يجلب الضرر لجسد الانسان يمكن
ان يقوم من خلاله شيء مفيد لهذا الجسد
يمكن اصلاح ما يتم افساده عن طريق
السيجاره ولا لا ما يستقل يعني انت طرحته
بشكل
يعني
الحقيقه كل شيء الانسان بيتناوله في ضرر
وفي فايده حتى الاكل المتناول يوميا في له
اضرار وفي له فوائد بس دائما نحن بنقرر
ممارساتنا وسلوكياتنا بناء على التوازن او
على ميزانها الاضرار والفوائد فالمفروض
نحن بسلوكياتنا نتبع الامور اللي فائدتها
بتغلب ضررها للاسف في اشياء كتير بنعملها
بحياتنا هايدي القاعده ما بتنطبق عليها
مثال منها هو التدخين وتدخين السجائر
وتدخين الشيشه وهالامور هذه اللي هي اثبتت
انه ضررها يعني بسوي اكثر بكثير من من
الالكترونيه اللي طبعا مروجينها بيتحدثوا
عن انها افضل بكثير من السجائر التقليديه
ولكن لغايه الان ما في زي ما كنا عم نحكي
دراسات طويله الامد تورجينا شو ضرر هذه
السيجاره على المدى البعيد بس انا بدي
اركز على نقطه ثانيه الخبر اللي اخذناه من
استراليا بيتحدث عن انه ضروره وجود شهادات
طبيه لحتى يكون في عند الشخص تصريح انه
يدخن السجائر الالكترونيه شو ممكن هاي
الشهاده تكون يكون فيها مثلا نوع المقصود
فيها انه
يمكن
ما فيك تشتري سيجاره الكترونيه غير بوصفات
طبيه
مين الدكتور اللي رح يوصف سجائر الكترونيه
كوصبه طبيه كعلاجة ما هو المشكل الجدل
القائم من لما طلعت السجائر الالكترونيه
تروجت بالسوق وصارت الحملات الدعائيه على
انه هي اقل ضررا من السجائر ومن التختخين
خليني اقولها بهالطريقه
[موسيقى]
اللي هو التبخيض بسائل وما بين ايضا تسخين
السجائر اللي هي من غير من غير اشعال الها
وبالتالي حرق صح هذه هذه اللي هي التسخين
يقول لك لا هذه ما فيها مشكله الرئه اللي
تحصل مع فبالتالي من الممكن ان تكون هي
التي تكون الصحيه او تحمل الفيتامينات
خلينا بس نوضح مساله معينه هي منين اجت
ترويج انه السيجاره والتدخين السيجاره
العاديه بتحتوي على 7000 ماده ضار اليس
النيكوتين فقط وليس القطران
ومنها مثل ما بنعرف الامونيا
والكربون اللي هني موعد ضاره جدا
الترويج للسياره الالكترونيه قالت انه
المواد مش موجوده فيه فيها ولكن
اثبت لحد هلا الفورمه مثلا بعض المواد
المصارنه موجوده بالسياره الالكترونيه
اللي كنت الفكره اللي بدي اوضحها انه في
سهوله بالتدخين للاسف هلا المشكله مثلا
بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه انه عملوا
دراسه لقوا التلاميذ
هني الاكثر
من يعني عم يدخنوا بالمدارس
تدخنها في المجمعات التجاريه في في اماكن
مغلقه فبالتالي هي اليوم اصبح حقيقه
الخطوه الاستراليه هي بدايه الحظر بدال
الهيئات الصحيه وبتصور حنتبع هالمسار هذا
ونلاقي على الاقل للاسف انتهى وقتنا انا
كنت حابه اسالك على شو قصه
سجائر الفيتامينات بس على كل حال للاسف
انتهى وقتنا يمكن نتحدث بشكل مفصل في
حلقات قادمه الدكتور منصور طبعا كان معنا
الاخصائي في امراض الجهاز
التنفسي وطب العنايه المركزه شكرا لك
دكتور
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات